[Music]
the milkis rs.1000 isn't a car for
everyday driving its suspension is very
hard and there's little noise damping
still this vehicle is something special
it was the only series production sports
car ever made in communist East Germany
volkmar crew spec owns the last one ever
made he says what makes the car fun to
drive is that it's just over 1 metre
tall so you're literally sitting 10
centimeters over the road and have a
very interesting perspective and of
course there's the mid-engine with his
rear transmission he says weather and
other conditions permitting the car
drifts nicely 101 Mel cous RS were built
between 1969 in 1984 many Vaught bug
parts went into their construction
that's why the milkis is often called a
wolf and sheep's clothing because it
looks faster than it actually is
depending on the engine it can reach
between 160 and 210 kilometers an hour
[Music]
Meyer explains at height smokeless
developed the car in 1969 it was East
Germany's answer to Western racecars the
RS 1000 had a fiberglass body with an
aluminum skin had used lots of standard
parts from the varberg 353 like this
turn signal the cars chassis was based
on that model - Chris Peak says here
there's the steel frame with independent
suspension there are the disc brakes on
the front axle it's all mechanically
operated with no brake booster no power
assisted steering
the cars front brakes wheel suspension
floor pan and braking system are also
taken from the Varberg 353 the Goldwing
doors give the milkis an exotic look for
a communist-era vehicle Chris big points
out the two separate gas tanks above the
rocker panel one on the left and one on
the right which holds 25 liters apiece
the steering instruments transmission
and electronics are also borrowed from
Bart board who speak shows us another
special thing about the malkos the ride
height of the seats can be adjusted
after lifting the seat to the desired
position
a wooden board is laid under it here
it's high now it's well it's practical
and simply crisp big notes that the
engine is located ahead of the rear axle
and the transmission behind this model
from 1984 was fitted with a 102
horsepower engine with a kerb weight of
680 kilos that made for a sporty Drive
he's in fox-like but this car's engine
isn't the original one instead of the
standard Varberg 3 cylinder this mochas
is powered by a four-cylinder BMW engine
plenty of power combined with a
lightweight makes for great driving
performance but drivers should be
careful not to push the Milkha's past
its limits
[Music]
Chris peak says the cars acceleration is
a real treat but he warns you need to
keep your hands firmly on the steering
wheel and always be ready to brake
because as he said before the car has no
brake boosters and the engine is a bit
too powerful for the series production
Varberg brakes anglish 30 burns in the
autumn is arrogant but for some Vinick
people both overseas also house max from
chi design because we take the party's
in fatso
regular maintenance is also very
important
Chris big always gives his milkis a
thorough checkup before a long trip if
the car has a powerful engine and runs
in the high revs so it's wise to check
the oil before setting out it's a relief
if the cars not using too much oil that
crews big nose all as well the last one
is ok I'm done quitting life to be on
the safe side crispy adds a bit of
coolant and wipes the radiator cap
then he checks the oil and finally the
trunk lid which can spring open while
the car is in motion
krispy says that can happen if you don't
monitor the tension of the Bowden cables
then the trunk can fly open it goes down
again but it's an unpleasant surprise he
ensures the cables are pre-loaded to
avoid this he also checks the insulation
here which sometimes comes loose
especially in hot weather but it's in
place so everything's wonderful
due to its stiff suspension the milk is
oversteers when taking curves at high
speed so drivers need to be very
reactive Chris pig likes the way the car
holds the road it's wonderful in dry
weather but when it's wet you need to be
careful as it tends to oversteer
otherwise the handling is very good
personally he thinks 150 kilometers an
hour is fast enough though you can go
180 or 190 but then he says you feel
uplift at the front and would be well
advised to take your foot off the gas he
thinks 130 to 150 kilometers an hour is
plenty fast for a car that is
essentially of art bore
there are some 80 mill coos rs.1000 s
around so grab one while you can those
in good condition sell for around 60,000
euros in Germany